joining me now is texas lieutenant
governor dan patrick texas provided a
possible preview
of the 2022 midterm elections this
weekend in the sixth district
republicans won by such an enormous
amount
they blocked all the democrat candidates
from competing in the runoff
that's not what was predicted dan i
remember i think we had you on
last year maybe a little bit maybe
almost a year and a half ago now
when all those articles were being
written about how the democrats are
going to flip texas
to democrat how are things looking today
it's not looking good for them the the
district you're talking about
the republicans won it by three points
in november and congressman wright died
from coven
so his wife supported by donald trump
ran in a field of 23
she finished first another republican
jake elsie finished second
the democrat law in a field of 23 where
they had the really the whole field of
themselves to be
really the only major democrat didn't
even make the runoff
so that was a seat they thought they
could flip uh they won't get that seat
back
but a lot of other things happen laura
this weekend as you and i kind of
chatted about a little bit
you mentioned the south lake school
board the parents stood up and took
took two seats back because they didn't
want critical race theory
the senate the chamber that i'm
president of we passed out a bill
banning critical race theory
and 1619 as so did the texas house and
we'll get one of those bills to the
governor's desk
also this weekend in austin the liberal
bastion of this
state uh democrats 60 of those who voted
in favor of restoring a camping ban you
see
mayor adler the super uber liberal mayor
of
austin had removed the camping ban and
homeless is
all over the city of austin crime is up
panhandling up
so in a very liberal city democrats even
push back against their own liberal
democrats so they're restoring
the camping ban and putting criminal
penalties on panhandling in lubbock
texas
the first sanctuary city the biggest
rather
in texas for life the people voted 60 40
roughly
in the city of lubbock there will be no
more abortion in that city a sanctuary
city
for life and as you and you talked about
our economy
you know i was on with you a lot during
covent and you know i'm the person that
said i'm not listening to fouchy anymore
i think i've been proven right who
who pays attention to him anymore and i
also said texas was on the right path
we are our economy is booming our
comptroller gave us stats today
we had the biggest increase in sales tax
ever wow and we're not just comparing
our numbers to last year because that
would be easy to say
to last year we're going back to two
years when everything was right laura
our economy is booming
and what the new york post said today is
true all those states
those blue states have ruined
livelihoods they've driven people out of
business
well and and no more people you know
they didn't save any more lives and
than we did in the red states like texas
and florida our economies are booming
conservative
republican policies and donald trump
policies are winning
how much influence did donald trump have
in that six-district runoff in the
election before the runoff
uh picking of course endorsing the uh
deceased candidate's wife
yes well i think he had a lot of
difference you know when you have it was
an open
it was an open primary because of the
death of the congressman and so when you
have 23 candidates it's tough for anyone
to get traction because it's so divided
and that was him she finished first
because of his endorsement i think
says all you need to hear about how much
his endorsement
is we had a role we got a role uh
lieutenant governor patrick but
imagine how well texas would be doing
if biden got off the backs of the oil
and gas industry
i mean he's artificially holding back
exploration
and and reducing supplies that's why the
price of of
gasoline is going up for every american
so there are a lot of shackles being put
on
um the fossil fuel industry because not
to mention the border
yeah and obviously open up gas and oil
for us yeah um lieutenant governor
patrick
great seeing you tonight hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else